acclaimed fashion designer christian
siriano is famous for the diversity of
his dresses and the models who wear them
the 36 year old known for designs that
straddle both the high end and the
affordable end of the fashion spectrum
since winning project runway back in
2007. i remember him from that season i
was watching he's become an author an
interior decorator and a furniture
creator and during the pandemic he led
an all hands on deck operation to
produce thousands of masks for first
responders christina raffini visited
siriano's new york city studio to find
out how he gets it all done
if clothes make the man or woman or
however you identify
christian siriano will make you
something unforgettable i think that
it's strange to tell someone they can't
wear something his glittering glamorous
and sometimes campy designs come in all
shapes and sizes and so do the people
who wear them do you have to be a size
zero to like high fashion
no and that's the best part i was sick
of customers saying like i can't
envision myself in this look and i was
like oh that's interesting like well
then i'm gonna show you
how you can envision yourself his shows
start here at his soho studio an
eight-minute walk from his apartment do
you walk and i walk every day rain or
shine rain or shine and let me tell you
being able to walk to your office is
is amazing especially when that office
extends to some of the world's most
high-profile red carpets
like the emmys
and the grammys
and fashion's biggest night we're
working on the meth ball just a few
weeks ago i was here every single day
all night of course of course i hear
that's a thing it's a thing it's a
horrible thing actually
siriano had three looks on the met gala
carpet this year but his ascension to
the heights of high fashion wasn't
exactly seamless in 2007 siriano burst
onto the pop culture scene for winning
the reality tv show project runway
just 21 years old he had to fight to be
taken seriously when you started the
reviews were not always so nice totally
i remember i read one that said your
your clothes were silly yeah or like or
too
too much was that a specific thing that
they were needling it was like they
couldn't figure it out his critics also
couldn't figure out why an aspiring
serious designer would want to make
cheaper collections for more affordable
brands did you shop at payless as a kid
i did of course so growing up i didn't
want to say no to that also because like
that's where i grew up like my mom is a
teacher like that we shopped there
my mom shopped at lane bryant i did a
collection for lane bryant and i also
was very excited i was never one to
alienate a customer you never know
someone can shop at payless one day
but you never know where they're
shopping 10 years later did you ever
have a moment of
like panic like maybe this isn't going
to work or or maybe that every day i
still have it it's great
dozens of successful collaborations and
more than a decade of runway shows later
so this is our world
i would like to live here please yes
live here please this is incredible but
if you live here you have to start
sewing
that's not going to go well for you
siriano has mastered the tool of his
tray i love the color of this dress i
actually have no idea where this woman's
going and she's fabulous and i'm like
where are you going like oh you don't
know where she's going in this dress
she just bought this dress and i swear i
hope she wears it to the grocery store
all these dresses are custom made to
order i'm pretty much in the whole
process starting with a sketch then
brought to life
stitch by meticulous stitch
one of the first things i noticed when i
walked in is also your mannequin bodies
are different sizes yeah every single
mannequin is a different size you know
because everybody's body is different
siriano's consistent willingness to
dress anybody and anybody has helped
earn him a stable of loyal celebrity
clients like lizzo lady gaga laverne cox
and leslie jones and i was like we're
gonna make you look incredible and she
looked like she felt oh my god we were
like this is your pretty woman moment
after jones tweeted that she couldn't
get a fancy designer to work with her
siriano replied with what else a raised
hand emoji you're coming out you're
going to wear this red gown you're also
going to show the world that like yes
you're tall and curvy but you also have
an amazing body she really does that
gown and dozens of others are now part
of an exhibit people are people on
display in atlanta i think it's
important for like other people to feel
represented and like celebrities on
screen oh my god that's someone with my
body type on screen and then they can
feel more comfortable with who they are
kelly dyer brought her daughter ruby i
try to teach my girls that you have your
body and you should be proud of it and
you can wear what you want and now i'm
getting emotional
do you have a favorite dress
a favorite dress no
impossible now i have had favorite like
moments um
like billy porter's oscar moment i think
was probably one of my favorite moments
in my career just because of what it
meant what did it mean i just think it
was
the ultimate
showcase of
what clothes can do to transform
someone's opinion about the world
because in syriano's world you can wear
whatever you want almost anywhere we
should be able to
walk and talk and be who we want to be
we're not carrying cancer here like it's
a dress calm down
so long as it makes you feel great
for cbs morning's christina raffini new
york that part of it the feeling great
as somebody who grew up as a kid that
was not a traditional size and didn't
have options when you find clothes that
make you feel the way you want to feel
that's right and make you see yourself
in a different way that's everything so
what he does for everyone of all sizes
completely hands down love it there
should be more designers that approach
it from that perspective that body
positivity for everybody should
represent
every woman every man yeah i mean he
says we're not curing cancer but you
could wear the dress to a cancer benefit
and steal the show on the red carpet as
you guys said that yellow dress that's
gayle's yellow we got we got to get that
dress for games christina rafini should
have had a dress made for herself in the
name of journalism in the name of yes
this time charge it to cbs otherwise
great story but missed opportunities